I have like a real thing about fast cars
that always have I'm here to show you
can drive a fast car be cool and still
get girls right and it's gonna break the
stereotype of what if sat on YouTube do
news about the women no not at all this
is about going fast that's what I'm here
to do and I want to do it in style what
do you know about mean I know it's
electric correct me if I'm wrong you
have to pay attention how much energy
you've got left in the car there's
boosts that go on during the race that
give you that advantage there's a lot
more changing around it's a bit more
exciting I'm a fan of Arkady style
racing games where a lot happens during
the race but I also want to have some
good food and drink a bit mumble here if
we could do that because I've heard
wines good in France
[Music]
the little dishes zucchini computer
surprise its wrangle like this stupid
things you can have in the Senate
let me kneel next to your table for five
minutes and read you a short story about
the food do you got this what do you
just love it
he tries weird sure you wouldn't either
we've had many nice meals together for
so many nama remember when we're in
further camera it occurs all excited
not far away from shuttle empty but you
know echo falls yeah
it's nothing like that trilliant a gross
pasta they must have known I was coming
I think he thinks we come from like the
arse end of no that love the big and so
Deena nice like a ham and cheese toastie
that your mum's be attend he likes lots
of diamonds it's lovely
with the wine great you've not got a
care in the world but what's on the
plane
yeah it's not like the stuff you get in
the supermarket it's very like chewy cut
out some chocolate
[Music]
what do you think welcome to Monaco very
chocolatey chance one they give me
energy
yes good
so over here a key phrase will be this
what is your deep all right go so best
kill cell differential did a little
Valentin
that there is where James Bond one
against look
so they say Brian Monaco is piloff oh
did your head your physical trouble sure
so they said that Monaco is who says
wikipedia says that monitors are half
the size of Central Park in Manhattan
oh it's a place you come and flex in it
you basically just come and like walk
around like calm and I just sorta but
you know I'm wondering if that's like
the future I think we just got paid to
get drunk yet on you and we're for the
racing and to be fair I'm totally with
that some cars yo-yo in them cuz it's
like speed with a Bentley it feels like
a drive in a hotel room like you're like
got everything luxury yeah it's tourists
everywhere building everywhere right
most cities in Europe this place just
isn't finished should we build something
else yeah we finished that okay start
again it's so funny to watch like
slender die this dream yeah it's nice
every other YouTube video that how much
can we do in this place in this time
[Music]
that's the real
to the German bollocks lithographer also
dinner
[Music]
come on baby but we gots to get in a
good time that's what the mo was wait
have a good time this time well I'm
having a good time
Prada case he wants a humbug
he wants out Casey who's Casey then kiss
all right let's say my she pick up a
handbag just cuz Brian really nice one
let's go really a check-in and is that
silk it feels like silk yeah we can't
afford the [__] tires on the same
strand place now the deposit for this is
like a [__] mortgage deposit that's
it and that's it they said it couldn't
be done they said a lot from the Council
of State in New Castle couldn't go from
an iPhone and an ironing board to drive
in a Lambo in Monaco this guy she's
asked me to move from the step as if I'm
riff raff to what do I look like riff
raff yeah so you riff raff
[Music]
oh [__] I don't belong in this city but
then I do that I really do I wanna say
this is a [__] dream I'm like
literally getting in the cars in the
state of shock I don't know like we
literally we're goin anywhere right now
there's no planets we've got no plan I
don't know how to [__] drive on the
wrong side of the road
I've got no idea we could end up
anywhere for Miller eat or meeow meeow
meeow
imma hold up to the Edition come you
tell her like totally freaked okay
literally he told me like two things
with ice up this provider that's to cook
there's police finders they know I
shouldn't be on the road
I don't need not indicate are genuine
into another Lawrence that's I yeah yeah
my heart's in my phenomenal right trying
to kill us again I'm also terrified fake
it to the Omega right now we are
northern to the guys behind me I think
should be police officers you yeah
I really shouldn't be in this unit
the definitely
we've just been tailed by the police I
don't think I look like I should be in a
car like this they've Sussman traffic
Yaris it meant to the foreign driving
alone statement will open in a [__]
300 Drive o'clock Oded dead she survived
Ordnung one of these this is I feel like
I could die at any moment
if we just draw off and they'd never
know I'm pretty sure I'm pretty sure
that he's got GPS on it or [__] I told
her how to get back middle look at the
clip paid to Jordan crushes Lamborghini
in Monaco I push it in the
apprenticeship was easy this is the
narrowest road I've ever driven up in my
life and I'm doing in a [__] London I
can't believe I thought this was a good
idea a right to eat what's left you know
[__] you very much Oh Lady I thought I'd
look cool I just looked terrified how's
it good new this is my wife's no I don't
know it's just so it's just how I'm
living I'm a youtuber I don't know say
yeah we just need somebody to sort of
just stop driving that's okay
[Music]
that my friend
is a Murcielago good shot but is a
rarity
all we need to do let's get down there
by the side the second were yacht party
that's just I don't know if it's my suit
thanks a lot see to cheater for inviting
us good guys no no I'm not I'm not
slugging people off what like it's me
it's Monica it's on it yeah it's not
really my sort of probably seeing ya
posh people
well Europe I'd say definitely people
who have privilege above us
yeah yeah so we're gonna go we're going
to try some the champagne see if there's
some hors d'oeuvres
I hear there's no auction so you might
be able to buy some stuff [__]
auction yeah and working charity auction
just got they've got money doesn't mean
I should have to pay for stuff bloody
they should be doing your bit though so
that's all was it for charity
yeah doing you've not done enough of
your face just probably yeah okay yeah
I'll do it
I'm not against charity it's just I
didn't need to be milking it's just to
get on there Jeremy I feel like false
promised let's go check it pally there's
a hot tub
welcome welcome come on in
the vessels are used to dawn I tell you
do you ever work it's eat less said
about that the better
I prefer not to talk about it just yeah
yeah yeah it's all right it's all right
so what are you doing New York did you
bring the brine any money that when we
leave you can just go fun coupons
sausage rolls would do I think Brian's
having a good time we got him on a boat
we gave him some alcohol just a little
bit of beer and he's ready to go well
fishery value Lauren to you like I'm
happy with that yes that's really good
what what is that Laurens quite sure
really is what I you like to eat
something I like than order is no now
I'm the opposite I like the adventure
just lovely partying or formula they
paid for something beautiful really put
on a lovely spread you've got to
appreciate the race tomorrow
yeah show some love I could just watch
the cosmos Michael three chairs for
Foreman if it will not be three teas but
that'll be enough that will not be
suffice the three J's and Mary you know
Robin sometimes I come to place like
this and I think so it's beautiful it's
absolutely beautiful
I need someone beautiful to be here with
honor
not bloody Lawrence and I mean romances
in the a and it's tangible views like
this maybe one day maybe one day
[Music]
go zap browser what a guy
so I'm gonna have the minestrone soup
followed by the Beast filler please all
their desserts at this thing the beef
filling
what do you do at one am I sure whiskey
in the middle of the night I know a lot
II can you believe that they're just
knock this over to one yeah mental isn't
it so we got the minestrone soup starter
we got a steak min if you want a bit of
much material boom Wow actually you're
welcome good evening
I would rise obviously fries and apple
sauce need all the energy exactly not
this review no I'm getting pushed to my
limits yeah
[Music]
it's this turn up they're ready for you
here yeah
listen to this
turtles Megan Sullivan
reading identity on this
[Music]
I feel more comfortable than at the dam
save other pros to it probably gonna
hopefully event
what mine does is leave a little space
for this a little space about a thousand
[Music]
appropriate for the bodies get more
subscribers
[Music]
no electrical man GTA Vice City I don't
know I'd love to play tonight
others in the Sun the Lambo with for the
lights change I'm more of a gta5 guy hey
Romans calling you Brian
Neko pellets no wonder JJ made a song
about this [__]
I have sold this cause of
bring a Buccaneer couple
all these people are excited come to see
me or whether they we're literally
walking where they'll be pulling in
getting their car so you know taking off
again it's pretty good sickening I kind
of live life on the edge sort of do what
I want Donna I think I could have been a
race driver which night just a little
too heavy
yes for the cause get me to the
racetrack these guys will not be the
hydros food sales and you are a truck
driver so
so in Formula e they give you the
sinkhole fund which we can increase the
chances of water looking guy who can win
Andre Lotterer
I'm good with him I see them last night
he called me Popeye I threatened a bunch
of instant friends see all the way limit
sites on this bad boy
[Music]
I'm not ready for this level of class in
my life and I apply that on all my
decisions it's sound like Audi sweets
quietly some food yeah says the e-tron
is like the family version of past [__]
loads of gadgets they've got cameras on
the inside of your Thor there's laws
don't don't know I've been a bit sort of
unsure on the electric sir I'm doing it
on on racers awesome practically not
sure off the infrastructures in the UK
for honest with you right okay but it is
coming and the more people who buy
electric cars the more demand there will
be and pulmonary is only raising their
awareness prior company month but the
thing is I mean one in the comedy food
feel this feeling Roman key on the
Lennon
Olivia Lee Rosen oh you know if you want
to hide an r8 or whatever just sort of
represent your prompt fun fact this
operates on the same battery power
charge is now four so you learnt
something new you Jeremy Clarkson didn't
tell you that did he what did he take
do you remember demolition cause of the
future that's what this is I hear that
that's two cars down the track warming
up see mother look
when is the car now
everything in short but impressive have
a good race he almost killed me I don't
know what kind of faces I was pulling so
basically get amongst the cars have a
good time something everyone really
loves the cause no some good news for
those who don't know he is like one of
the brains behind the kickoff show
and he's also formula so this is one big
tube right there that's where they said
I was the same person to him now you
know I love saying the look on people's
faces what do you think of the cars
close-up
[Music]
I think especially the halo victory
nothing to deal with a hill or just
raise your head when you're about to die
when you push over yeah yeah he tries to
get at the inside
most economists think is that exactly
sim so no change at the opening quarter
take the loop-de-loop
[Applause]
ladies sunny want to move from Lucas
Degrassi
was as good for you as it was for me
place
[Music]
robot just make this coffee
right
[Music]
the streak is over
[Applause]
that's it then go say goodbye to this
little fella it was emotional hmm
and also we had a great time of formula
e I want to do more troubling loads I
think you've finally won me over
yeah I've been lit a flame inside you
you have little fire up under my ass or
did formula e light a flame inside you
Brian maybe they just made it so
enjoyable as the car door and not flame
the electricity there's a spark there
Brian you might say yeah sort of there's
a high voltage running through you
anyway hopefully you've enjoyed this
video if you have leave a comment tell
us what you like do you want us to do
more troubling where should we go
let's Lawrence probably more Heineken
Fairplay subscribe if you haven't
already i'm formula a of course i'll
because if you want to see more of that
it's all there links in the description
below and we'll see his lair is that
silk feels like silk yeah
[Music]
can you see now half an hour late we've
got a little camera Robyn says fungi's
were not going really fast that should
hold on unfortunately were in a
Lamborghini so guys a wonderful size you
only on Tuesdays
[Music]
hello
three chairs for Foreman a little bit
already lovely three teas and this is
going down like Mother's Milk
[Music]
so basically our taxi driver he's gone
through a red light amaze the Queen
could have been hit as far as having
turned you put my life in jeopardy throw
the [__] book at him your life is not
in jeopardy I could have died to a far
from jeopardy Brian I could have died
can I just say like I did not [__]
what crime has he done mm-hmm I was
sitting there thinking is he a murderer
as he normally like taking people out no
have you ever seen the Bourne caliber
either you get in the taxi and then you
then you die by the way can I just say
how Peng was Angelina Jolie in that
movie she is she was prime if you
haven't seen it
born collect Angelina Jolie be on Sky on
demand go and check it out it's
fantastic wonderful let's wipe up now
it's all broad doable if you want to
check it out this fight
[Laughter]